i honestly don't know how it works in
other countries but here in italy for
each apartment block there's an
administrator who organizes general
meetings and manages all the paperwork
now imagine a condominium a big
condominium with 193 families that every
year as in all condos gather in an
assembly they discuss and approve
budgets vote for their chairmen argue
and complain to each other about their
neighbors but this assembly has some
peculiarities in fact every decision
approved here is in no way binding even
if you convince the entire building that
your neighbor mr city of pistoia has
taken too many liberties in the use of
common spaces nothing can stop him from
carrying on as he pleases only community
decisions regarding formal and
bureaucratic matters expenses and
budgets have any validity after all
that's what counts money is no joke and
you know how it goes no one rejoices at
the idea of being administrator and
president of an apartment block add
another element in addition to this
assembly there's another more restricted
embedding one a council whose authority
with all due respect to mr pistolia is
not in question there are 10 families
established by the assembly which
alternate for the next two years but to
these another five families are added
and these always have their place in the
council they will say that they built
the building and therefore well they own
it these are very special guys so
special that these five do not even
trust each other they have studied a
mechanism according to which even if one
of them is against the resolution the
resolution itself can be blocked this
means that if one of them let's say mr
vladimir decides to park his new flaming
car in front of the garage of another of
his colleague mr volodymir this council
cannot do anything because any decision
would require the favorable vote of mr
vladimir himself
now replace condominium with the un
family units with states mr pistolia
with any forgotten country awesome car
with russian tank and we're already well
on our way as for mr vladimir and mr
vladimir there's no need to change
anything we need to get straight to the
question of the day what's wrong with
the un on the one hand we have become
accustomed to the idea that the
decisions that count are always taken by
the usual five the so-called permanent
members of the un usa russia france uk
and the people's republic of china this
is the exclusive group the private party
that can always get away with it there
are proposals for a security council
more representative of the world
population or suggestions to extend the
permanent seat to brazil india and
germany or even to turn the french seats
into a larger eu seat but for the moment
we have to make do with the compromise
of the non-permanent members provided
that your country is lucky enough to end
up there at the right time this doesn't
undermine the fact that there's a
considerable gap between the
competencies of the assembly and those
of the council the only body that can
deliberate sanctions embargoes and even
military actions against possible
aggressors it is true however that
according to the article 27 of the un
charter two different majorities are
established each time depending on two
types of issues to be submitted to the
vote of the council there are procedural
matters there is the formal ones that
establish the course of the session
which require the favorable votes of at
least nine members both permanent and
non-permanent and then there are the
decisions on any other matter which
always require a majority of name votes
including those of the five permanent
members in a certain respect article 27
recognizes the superiority of some
states over all the others and here we
already have a first gearing note it is
up to the council alone or rather to the
five permanent members to establish what
is a threat to peace an aggression or an
act of conquest in some cases there is
not much to discuss such as the invasion
of kuwait in 1991 by saddam's iraq on
that occasion resolutions were issued by
calling for the withdrawal of iraqi
troops imposing sanctions and finally
with resolution 678 authorizing the use
of force to impose iraqi withdrawal but
it doesn't always work smoothly see what
happened in bosnia and somalia in a
sense rather than banning wars the
security council is the only body that
can recognize a state's right to wage
wars things would become much more
complicated if the bad guy was one of
the five permanent members and here we
have the second and main problem the
so-called vetoes actually the power of
veto is not explicitly mentioned in the
un charter and it's not a veto in a
strict sense according to the already
mentioned article 27 for all the issues
that are not procedural therefore issues
related to peace conflict resolution
sanctions and even the entry of
countries in the u.n the nine minimum
votes in favor must include the approval
of all the five permanent members and
therefore the contrary vote of one of
them implicitly becomes a kind of veto
in reality the negative opinion of one
of the five members cannot block the
deliberation from the beginning as a
pure veto right would allow but it can
only make it void during the voting
phase similarly even the non-permanent
members enjoy in theory a similar power
the so-called block v2 even if all the
five permanent members vote in favor
there would still be four votes missing
to reach a majority of nine and if the
non-permanent members would unite to
vote against the five other permanent
members well the party is compromised
for convenience as everyone does i will
call this prerogative by the term veto
even though it would be a misnomer for
some lawyers we would then have the
paradox of an aggressor country sitting
comfortably on its seat in the council
that find itself having to vote on the
resolution condemning its own actions in
your opinion will this nation block
itself with its veto or will it play
dumb and forget to vote against it the
answer is pretty clear yet such rebel
nation must still participate in the
discussion at least to get the scolding
from the other four this vital vita game
has already been abused in the 70s by
the five u.n members so nothing shocking
it was the soviet union that got into
right away however stalin in his
infinite wisdom decided to bycut the
sessions of the council when its members
continued to recognize taiwan rather
than mouse china
in the meantime in 1950 north korea had
invaded south korea and the security
council taking advantage of the soviet
absence approved resolutions on which
the soviet union would certainly have
vetoed from that moment onwards the
soviet union didn't skip any sessions
and put its veto on everything possible
but don't worry the other four didn't
stand by and watch united kingdom and
france used the right of veto for the
first time in 1956 during the switz
crisis that saw them involved together
with israel in the military occupation
of the canal against egypt
then in the 70s it was the turn of the
united states which exercised its right
of veto mainly in defense of israel from
the risk of sanctions
the ussr loved the use of the veto so
much that ambassador andrei gromeko
earned the nickname of mr nyet mr no
while vyacheslav molotov got the
nickname of mr vito anyway we did the
math for you the vital right has been
exercised 263 times sometimes by several
members together for 213 rejected
resolutions
russia ussr for 120 times then us at 82
united kingdom 29 france 16 and china
16. the vital right has often be used as
a kind of protection for one's own
interests something that has little to
do with achieving peace and harmony and
that's the contradiction the u.n is
supposed to be an equal organization yet
five countries can block everything and
okay these five countries are the
winners of world war ii but can france
and uk still be considered great powers
as in the 18th century at the time it
was roosevelt who named four policemen
to ensure peace in the world the three
were winners plus the republic of china
despite the fact that the latter wasn't
a political crisis all of these
according to a concept that was actually
very close to the classic divisions by
spheres of influence and let's take into
account that dozens and dozens of vetoes
have been used not to prevent
international crisis but to hinder the
appointment of general secretaries and
wars to prevent the entry of some states
into the u.n let's take an example the
people's republic of china replaced the
taiwanese in 1971 and immediately used
vetoes to prevent the entry of
bangladesh and other countries that were
still recognizing taiwan
we italians managed to enter the u.n
only in 1955 due to vetoes placed by the
soviet union this management system thus
seems to grant the five powerful
permanent members that no decisions they
don't like will ever be effective the
veto power somehow implies that nothing
can be done without the total
willingness of the big five basically
the world cannot be at peace if the big
five are not at peace the underlying
assumptions of the veto mechanism thus
seems to be that word order is not
possible if the big five don't agree
altogether as if to say if sanctions on
luka shankar may upset one of us who
knows who with the risk of creating
tensions between us then better not to
sanction him at all rather than a real
blockade some see the veto as a sort of
prevention a collective mechanism it's a
way to ensure that a conflict doesn't
break out among the five permanent
members which apparently is the most
important thing for our global stability
there are also those who argue that the
absence of the veto would create more
instability and so it would be right to
keep such veto vetoes proved their
validity only in cases of narrow
interest to the council itself and most
of the times vetoes weren't used to meet
humanitarian demands or to put an end to
international conflicts and so russia
vetoed the resolution to open an
investigation into the malaysian
airlines accident in dombas as well as
the condemnation for the annexation of
crimea
russia also vetoed together with china
the resolutions against the assad regime
in syria in 2011 and 2012 just as on the
other side the u.s vetoed the
recognition of the genocide in rwanda in
addition to this many says that the
continued u.s vetoes against sanctions
targeting israel are contributing to
exacerbate relations with the
palestinians mentioning syria aside from
russia and iran the big allies who had
supported its bombings and attacks the
us saudi arabia the emirates and turkey
have also been part of the clashes and
just as russia has violated the u.n
charter by bombing the aleppo region and
hundreds of civilian targets as well as
approving the use of chemical weapons by
the assad regime obama's and trump's u.s
did the same thing by launching more
than 50 tomahawk cruise missiles on
syria the americans bypassed the
constraints of the u.n charter that
limit the use of force in international
affairs and in the end the u.n security
council still can't agree on a joint
agreement on syria russia has repeatedly
blocked negotiations moved by the other
three western nations for their own part
the united kingdom france and the us
have done the same with the russian
demands calling them excessive and
unacceptable and so the endless game
continues
so it's pretty normal to expect that a
council structured in this way is going
to be unable to take action in conflicts
or global dimensions right because such
conflicts may involve a permanent member
for these dn members have been
discussing a possible suspension or
expulsion of russia from the un and the
security council in order to bypass its
v2 in the resolutions concerning ukraine
beside the fact that the possible veto
of china would still remain it's really
possible to exclude russia the first
step has already been taken in this
sense with the suspension of moscow from
the un human rights council at least
until 2023 an action made possible by
the decision of the general assembly
alone only libya suffered a similar fate
in 2011 but here with russia we are
dealing with a member of the council
beyond its symbolic significance this
measure denies russia the possibility to
propose resolutions and amendments in
situations in which it's not directly
involved however suspending russia from
the un and therefore from the security
council is more complicated and
according to many analysts actually
impossible according to article 5 the
assembly could decide with two-thirds of
voting favor the suspension of a u.n
country but only against those countries
towards which the security council has
initiated proceedings in other words
it's necessary to ask russia first if
it's okay to be suspended then it was
also discussed the very borderline
hypothesis of denying the russian
delegation the credentials to represent
its country from documentation to the
recognition of its delegates this is a
procedure that is normally implemented
for those countries where a kudata or
civil war undermines the legitimacy of
the government and consequently the u.n
delegation this happened recently in the
cases of afghanistan myanmar and
cambodia in 1997. however russia doesn't
have a similar situation but it's clear
that the intervention in ukraine
according to the un chart which by the
way no one seems to respect anymore is a
clear violation of international law but
according to some it would be possible
to exclude russia even though it doesn't
have a coup d'etat or a civil war the
same thing had already been done with
regard to south africa in 1974.
at first the security council rejected a
resolution to suspend the african
country requested as a measure in
response to the upper side regime in
case you were asking vetoed by the us
france and the uk nevertheless the
general assembly symbolically refused to
approve the south african credentials to
the point of deciding to no longer admit
the south african delegation to the
assembly at least until 1994 with the
end of upper tide and here we should
stress the sentence don't try this at
home maybe the safest way to solve the
un dilemma is for the suspension to
mature within the console itself which
is obviously impossible at the moment
and finally the question we can help but
ask ourselves is who knows what chavez
would have done with his little guitar
or gaddafi with his uninterrupted
monologue of an hour and a half perhaps
to find a way out of this quagmire it
takes just the right amount of madness
ciao